ich war heute bei einem dreh zusammen
mit kelly und freddy kammer und dann war
ich jetzt gerade mal wieder auf den
kanälen von den beinen und hat bei
frieden video gesehen wo er auf
gutefrage.net fragen reagiert hat
deswegen befinden wir uns hier auf der
seite gute frage hätte und bei uns
man kann die bei watson und top
informiert sein okay das ist heute nicht
das video thema sondern park unfall
fahrerflucht erst strafgeld vom staat
jetzt will versicht darüber habe ich
eine klausur geschrieben und ihr habt
ich sowas von in den sand gesetzt wir
werden heute einfach mal hier oben in
die suche gehen und einfach mal nach
irgendwas suchen was vielleicht
irgendwelche komischen fragen sind luca
ist auf gutefrage.net lukas auf
gutefrage.net luca ist auf gutefrage.net
und ich will sagen jetzt an
jetzt sind konkreter es kay und
krankhafter brüder die sehen so ähnlich
aus sind die brüder ok hammer
punktierung hammer satzbau hammer
grammatik diese frage wurde gestellt von
im google fast zwei jahre dabei und null
punkte war der previews als krankhafter
sind brüder oder halt konkreter ist nur
mit ihnen befreundet
krankhafter ja krank kraft
ich könnte heulen sind geschwister war
crafter ist nur mit denen befreunden
okay das sind auf jeden fall war auch
was ist das denn da am rand sind com
crafter und tran crafter ein paar wollt
ihr mich komplett verarschen ich denke
die haben das video gold freitag nur
spaß gemacht wenn du mich fragst nein
sind sie nicht allerdings kann man das
nicht genau wissen außer man kennt sie
persönlich wie oft noch wir sind kein
paar wir sind nicht zusammen dass wir
hier schön geschäft notice sohn oder
nicht mit freunden auf die bettdecke der
schwester alles klar dass videos gerade
bei einem schnitt hier im robus sieben
minuten lang und jetzt sind wir hier
schon beim onanieren mit freunden auf
die bettdecke der schwester
es geht um eine bekannte sie hat einen
sohn 15 jahre alt und eine tochter zwei
jahre
die haben
abgespritzt auf eine decke von einem
mädchen das zwei jahre alt ist
hast du so was auch schon mal gemacht
bisher das zwischen uns ist das ist so
das ist dass das läuft das ist gerade
erhalten
der sohn ist wie soll ich sagen ein
chaot alles klar
da wird direkt in die erste person
wieder beleidigt er lässt sich nicht
viel sagen und macht halt was er will
seine freunde sind nicht viel besser vor
einer weile hat sie die winter wird
decke der kleine aus dem schrank geholt
weil es ja nun langsam winter wird da
bemerkte sie auf der decke mehrere
spermaspuren und flecken alles klar die
zweijährige hat zu ihrer hat zu der
mutter gesagt wahrscheinlich soja oder
sein sperma flecken auf der decke mit
zweijährige dazu muss man sagen dass die
decke aus platzgründen im schrank des
sohnes lag eigentlich kommen ja nicht
viele verdächtige in frage das kann ja
nur der sohn alleine oder mit seinen
freunden zusammen sein alltag
ich frage jetzt mal alle die schon
einmal selbst onaniert haben habt ihr
schon mal mit euren freunden zusammen
getan
nein
gut so weil liberi sie suchen ich werde
hier extra keine namen zensieren weil
ich meinen ihr seht ihr die frage und
dann können jetzt bei google eingeben
dann habt ihr die frage eher angezeigt
ich denke nicht dass er das zusammen mit
seinen freunden gemacht hat wo sie hat
vier punkte alter sie ist damit jetzt
ein spitzenreiter also ich muss wirklich
sagen die beste antwort auf diese frage
wirklich bwo gefragt wurde ja oder hat
junge auf die bettdecke von der
schwester onaniert an schlaf doch im
sitzen
ich muss wirklich sagen user mit dem
namen julie 123 du alter du kriegst in
dieser folge den preis für die beste
antwort der dünnen gürtel wie im hotel
als mädchen masturbieren sind das hier
ernst gemeinte fragen wir fliegen morgen
für drei wochen weg und das problem ist
dass ich mit meiner cousine einen raum
teilen muss und nie alleine sein werde
ohne selbstbefriedigung bin ich sehr
launisch und haben gemeinsam ich brauche
es ein mal am tag auf dem kloses
bestimmt sehr unbequem und so komme ich
nie zum höhepunkt was soll ich machen
ernst gemeint okay die frage ist
wirklich ernst gemeint ich will mich
hier gar nicht über irgendwas muss ich
machen aber wir sind derzeit voll in der
sex schiene hier hilfe ich glaube ich
bin schwanger mit elf mit cousine
schlafen cousine geil finden teil nicht
warum kennen die vögel nur auf mein auto
auf dem parkplatz bei der arbeit sind
auf den bäumen verdammt viele schwarze
vögel am abend also die sind immer
nachts da ich habe ein schwarzes auto
auf dem parkplatz stehe ich nicht immer
eine gleichstellung es gibt auch andere
schwarze autos das problem ist die kacke
immer nur auf mein auto
vielleicht nehmen wir die leute mit den
anderen autos wo kacke drauf legt
einfach die kacke von ihren autos und
schmeißen sie auf dein auto drauf wenn
das kein scherz ist dann hol dir eine
plane die duh drüberziehen kannst gibt
es für jedes auto ja war oder ist die
plane voll gepackt und dann brauchst du
jeden tag neue plan
hier schreibt jemand könnt ihr mir
helfen ich suche einen hack für coc oder
boom bietet kostenlos fürs handy
allerdings hat er in die frage
geschrieben boom beach oder ct kg hannah
16 duo
bin ich auf deine
viel kann mir jemand erklären was
tomatensaft mit luca konkret zu tun hat
lieber user mit dem namen farben los
spitzenreiter tomatensaft ist bei mir
das ist das hat bei mir angefangen weil
der liebe es denn mir dann klipp
zugesendet hat mit tomatensaft und dann
habe ich darauf reagiert und das war's
ich habe voll hunger gerade warum
bekomme ich hier nur so sechs sachen
angezeigt alter war wie kann das sein
warum schreiben eigentlich so viele das
wort dorf zu dorf gott auch wieder hier
nach einer antwort sommerloch 20.10 weil
sie doch sind
alter
was sind das für
fast verantworten weil sie dorf sind
alter mit doppel und doppel app wollte
mich komplett verarschen also ich weiß
nicht wie die gutefrage.net das mit den
kukis macht auf der website aber hier
steht einfach so kriminellsten gängen
der welt und dann darunter minecraft
server wie kann man bei einem server im
bild vormachen in der server liste
inwiefern sind diese beiden in
irgendeiner beziehung zueinander dass
sie hier unter einander stehen alter ich
will hier gar nicht so fragen daran
nehmen ob ich irgendwie was ist das denn
lippen aufspritzen otero wollte mir in
nächster zeit in der m1 klinik in
frankfurt mir die lippen aufspritzen mit
bilodeau gibt es einige erfahrungen mit
dieser klinik und dem höher lara an
stoff bilodeau ruft woods die
konsequenzen erst mal schreiben an
motorrad girl 08 sie ist seit fast drei
jahren dabei hat einen punkt und will
sich jetzt die lippen aufspritzen lassen
warum machen menschen das überhaupt ich
finde es so unschön wenn man irgendwas
an seinem körper verändert das ist auch
einfach nur er werde vorerst
rapportierte vpn euch das ganze gefallen
hat dann lass dir einmal like da schreib
mir mal die kommentare ob ich vielleicht
normalen video dazu machen soll in der
mich dann beispielsweise mal selber
fragen stelle und dann auf die antworten
warten
[Musik]